[Musique]
alors comment pouvons-nous expliquer que
certaines personnes osent alors que
d'autres n'osent pas comment peut
expliquer que par exemple antoine
griezmann à qui on a dit qu'il était
trop petit pour faire du football et a
été rejetée par quatre clubs puissent
obtenir la coupe du monde
comment on peut expliquer qu'une
personne comme charles aznavour ses
professeurs de chant lui ont dit qu'ils
n'avaient ni la taille lit la voix et
qu'ils feraient mieux de changer de
carrière puisse devenir une légende de
la chanson comment on peut expliquer
finalement que certaines personnes
arrivent à dépasser transcender la peur
qu'on peut avoir quand parle en public
ou la peur liée au regard des autres une
des peurs les plus importantes pour
l'être humain c'est la peur d'être exclu
du cercle social
la peur d'être rejetés et par
conséquence vous appelle à être effrayé
à l'idée du jugement ou du regard des
autres
ça fait 15 ans que je peux pas sur cette
question et ça va amener à faire trois
découvertes qui ont radicalement changé
ma manière d'observer de voir ce
qu'était le regard des autres la raison
pour laquelle ça me passionne autant ce
sujet c'est que j'étais un jeune homme
qui était mal dans ma peau avec des
pensées de suicide
j'avais du mal à oser lever la main en
cours a abordé cette fille qui me
plaisait du mal à être moi-même et
j'arrive et même d'ailleurs à faire une
excellente performance qu'il est capable
même soir d'être précoces et d'avoir une
panne ce qui n'est pas donné à tout le
monde saint servan du coup je me suis
lancé un défi et le défi de faire plein
de choses que je connaissais pas et qui
m'effrayait lie au regard des autres ça
a commencé avec le fait de lever la main
en cours des potes me disais mais tu
penses que tu vas un jour arriver à être
confiants en levant la main en cours
tout le monde sait faire ça à l'époque
j'étais trop stressée pour pouvoir
répondre que oui mais c'était bien la
seule idée que j'avais alors j'ai levé
la main en cours aborder des centaines
d'inconnus aller voir ses filles qui me
plaisait par leur public
monsieur me lancer le défi d'aller dans
des boîtes de lui ai parlé à la première
moitié de la boîte de nuit leur dire
bonjour et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que la deuxième moitié de la
boîte de nuit celle qui arrive après
bah du coup elle se dit mais qui sait ce
type où tout le monde lui dit bonjour
dire qu'en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que vu que tout le monde a peur du
regard des autres et tout le monde a
envie dans les yeux de l'autre de
paraître important du coup la première
moitié de la botte de lui dès qu'ils
passent à côté de moi je vous salue donc
j'avais des gens qui me demandait mais
est ce que tu es le fils du patron est
ce que tu es célébrités qui tu es et ça
va fasciner de veut dire que quelques
détails dans votre communication de
manière de respirer pouvait tout changer
donc je me suis dit je vais lancer une
chaîne youtube j'étais encore stressé
pas très à l'aise mais j'ai envie de
partager au plus grand nombre
comment faire pour arriver à être plus à
l'aise donc je démarre ma chaîne youtube
j'avais plusieurs jours a osé me filmer
je vais plusieurs jours a osé mettre ma
vidéo sur youtube en privé et je mets
plusieurs jours a osé cliquez sur le
bouton publier parce que je me dis mais
qu'est ce qu'on va penser de moi c'est
drôle d'ailleurs notre cerveau parce que
j'imagine que d'un coup la terre entière
va voir ma vidéo alors il ya un milliard
de vidéos
j'ai trois abonnés moi mon deuxième
compte la mer et il ya un type qui sort
de nulle part je pense que youtube a
embauché une bande de cousins là pour
entraîner les personnes qui ont du mal
avec le regard des autres est un type
qui sort de nulle part et qui marque
david tu mérite pas de vivre
j'en rigole aujourd'hui j'ai pas
vraiment rigoler sur le coup j'ai
continué de faire des vidéos plusieurs
centaines de vidéos chaque vidéo essayer
de faire quelque chose de différent de
nouveau faire des vidéos dans le métro
vers des vidéos dehors
et si d'apprendre à devenir un meilleur
communicant et un jour j'ai un pote qui
m'appelle c'est un des fondateurs d'un
des plus gros incubateur de start up en
europe
il m'appelle david je vais à diffuser
une de tes vidéos à toutes les start up
alors sur le coup je dis mais je suis
trop content pas merci c'est top de la
confiance que tu es en moi et je dis
quel vie noté choisi il dit de tes
premières j'ai pourquoi t'as fait ça
pourquoi une des premières
hier je sais ce que je fais je vais
attendre quelques semaines et je vais
leur donner des dernières jamais
pourquoi tu fais ça
il dit je veux leur montrer que vraiment
tout est possible et sur le coup
exactement comme vous je me dis c'est
une critique c'est qu'est ce qui veut
dire par là ça m'a amené à faire comme
si les trois découvertes qui ont
transmis ma vision alors je vous montre
cette image ça c'est l'image des
premières vidéos où j'avais testé les
t-shirts je m'étais dit la marche pas ça
à cause du costume donc je mets un
costume et j'ai un type pareil qui sort
de nulle part qui dit il faut que tu
arrêtes de mettre le costume de ton père
ça n'était pas le costume de mon père
mais je comprends pourquoi disait sa
grâce à lui d'ailleurs j'ai changé de
costume est en fait je me suis rendu
compte que je m'étais énormément de
valeur sur les critiques y avait
toujours des gens qui me disaient tu es
trop jeune pour pas y arriver arrivera
jamais tu t'exprimes pas assez bien et
je m'étais trop d'énergie là dessus trop
de poids à ce que les autres pensaient
de moi donc j'ai continué je me suis dit
qu'est ce que ça pourrait être un défi
qui vraiment me fait flipper en partant
d'un ancien timide le truc était le plus
stressant pour moi c'était de louer une
salle
donc j'ai loué une salle de 1400
personnes et je me suis dit j'ai un mois
pour faire un one man show
sachant que j'ai demandé à plusieurs
personnes autour de moi qui m'ont dit en
un mois jamais tu pourras faire une
bonne chose ça impossible donc j'ai
réservé une salle ça donnait ça 1400
personnes
j'étais terrorisée sincèrement avant de
monter sur scène je pense que j'ai
jamais été autant de fois aux toilettes
en vingt minutes avant de monter sur
scène et ça m'a permis d'avoir ma
première découverte l'entraînement le
fait de s'entraîner tous les jours à
faire des choses que tu ne connais pas
le fait de te dépasser le fait de te
remettre en question et pourquoi pas
apprendre des critiques parce qu'ils
aient des critiques qui était
intéressante me suis rendu compte que
l'entraînement ça rend obsolètes les
critiques dire qu'il ya plein de gens
qui ont dit tout un tas de choses sur le
fait que je pourrais pas y arriver mais
quand toi t'es pas concentré sur les
écoutes avait concentré sur apprendre et
faire des choses que tu ne connais pas
et bien finalement le temps qu'ils aient
fini de parler toi tu a progressé et
j'aimerais du coût partagé aujourd'hui
cette idée et cette invitation à les
faire des choses qui sont challenger
pour soi alors chacun sa taille
aujourd'hui j'ai le privilège la chance
de côtoyer rencontrer et interviewer
accompagner des personnes qui excellent
dans leur domaine producteurs du cinéma
aux anneaux des sportifs olympiques des
champions du monde des entrepreneurs qui
génère plusieurs dizaines de millions
d'euros
je veux vous dire d'ailleurs que peu
importe là où ils en sont tous sur terre
il ya quelque chose qui nous fait peur
les au regard des autres et mon
invitation
c'est à dire qu'est ce que je peux faire
qu'il fait vraiment flipper et qui peut
être va me permettre en plus d'être
fière de moi être là avec vous ça me
permet de repenser à ce jeune homme que
j'ai été de me dire waouh ça me
paraissait impossible et ça allait au
delà de ce que j'imaginais parce que ça
a démarré avec un truc où mes potes
foutez de ma gueule qui était de lever
la main en cours je suis aller toujours
plus loin dans cette es fille je me suis
dit ok qu'est ce qui me ferait encore
plus flipper que le spectacle et on va
partir aux états unis et je vais
annoncer à tout le monde sur ma chaîne
youtube et partout le plus possible que
je vais interviewer 30 américains
considérés comme inaccessibles
sachant que quand j'annonce ça j'ai
aucune idée de comment je vais faire
donc je me retrouve à new york première
fois à new york je sais pas comment je
vais faire pour interviewer quelqu'un et
j'obtiens l'interview avec 16 go dean
qui est un peu légende aux états unis du
marketing c'est quelqu'un qui accompagne
et yahoo
à la fin de l'interview il me dit quand
est ce qu'il est en train
sous-entendu ce serait bien que tu
dégages sur le quai du train c'est ma
première interview de toute ma vie à new
york aux états unis et je en train de
réaliser que j'ai certainement raté une
des acteurs voulait plus importante de
ma vie
la raison pour laquelle j'ai raté cette
interview c'est qu'en fait mon anglais
est pourri donc cette godet c'est
quelqu'un qui passe hothead aux états
unis le plus gros t'aide à la télé à la
radio et qui habitués à raconter des
blagues c'est que quand il raconte une
blague il habitué que les gens rigolent
mais vu que j'ai un mauvais anglais
quand il raconte des blagues je ne
comprends pas que c'est une blague ou
des fois je comprend deux minutes plus
tard c'est la raison pour laquelle les
pros et mes interviews suivante quand tu
les regardes ça ma chaîne youtube
américaine tu vois que je rigole dans le
doute alors que est des moments où je
rigole ça n'a rien à voir et c'est pour
ça que j'ai plein de commentaires de ce
type là sur ma chaîne youtube américaine
alors c'est la traduction super
interview côté de l'interviewer donc pas
moi mais si j'entends encore ce frenchy
boys et de traductions pouffer derrière
comme une fille est trop petit point des
comme ça j'en ai des centaines des gens
qui m'ont dit que ce serait mieux que
j'arrête de parler anglaise que ça leur
fait mal à l'oreille des gens qui m'ont
dit que vraiment c'était les déshonorer
ces gens là que des interviews avec mon
anglais de merde alors du coup je me
suis lancé le défi parler par exemple
devant 200 personnes qui étaient les
dirigeants de boîtes de snp 500 c'est un
peu comme le cac 40 est la fin de mon
intervention j'ai quelqu'un qui va voir
l'animateur et qui le dit mais pourquoi
lui
mais sincèrement je veux dire pourquoi
lui il ya tous des excellents et
pourquoi lui j'ai un autre qui vient
voir l'animateur et qui dit tu sais dans
tous les intervenants
il a qu'un seul que je retiendrai j'ai
pas tout compris ce qu'il a raconté
mais par contre je pense que notre
entreprise
elle a un peu plus besoin de l'état
d'esprit qu'il a eue faire dix mille
kilomètres à l'est par les langues qui
connaît pas devant des personnes qu'il
impressionne
je pense que si on faisait un peu plus
ça dans notre entreprise il va ya
peut-être des trucs qui pourrait se
passer alors je commence à me poser des
questions est-ce qu'il ya que moi qui
suis critique et donc je suis allé sur
internet sur un site qui s'appelle
allociné voir mon film préféré ce que
les gens pensaient et cinq oscars
deuxième meilleur film box office monde
l'année de sa sortie
et quand tu vas sur allociné que tu
regardes les commentaires les plus
mauvais tu as des personnes qui sont
sincères et je vous en ai sélectionné
trois que j'ai vu aujourd'hui j'ai
trouvé magnifique alors le premier c'est
sans aucun doute un des films les plus
raté de l'histoire du cinéma
bref une daube magistral ok c'est mon
film préféré
le film est tellement nul que le qu'il
devienne une parodie les joueurs jouent
mal et n'a aucun charisme et le dernier
je les trouvais efficace insupportable
et ça m'a soulagé ça m'a soulagé parce
que je me suis cycle aviateurs
les gens peuvent dire ça franchement
tout est possible pour moi non ça m'a
soulagé ça m'a donné ma deuxième
découverte c'est qu'en fait quoi que tu
fasses tu peux être le meilleur sportif
au monde tu peux être michael jordan
tu peux être kobe bryant tu peux être
n'importe qui excellait passé toute sa
vie à essayer d'exceller dans un domaine
l'art la science l'entrepreneuriat tu
aura toujours des gens pour dire que ce
que tu fais c'est pourri et le pire
c'est qu'ils sont sincères mais c'est
une deuxième découverte importante pour
moi et qui s'est appuyé par des travaux
scientifiques donc gerald rice qui est
professeur à l'université à londres et
en fait il s'est rendu compte que notre
cerveau chaque être humain un cerveau
qui est différent et donc par
conséquence notre perception du monde
elle est différente pour chaque personne
et c'est la raison pour laquelle ce qui
est important pour toi pour d'autres
c'est pourri et c'est une bonne nouvelle
en fait on peut se libérer l'idée que
d'autres personnes puissent le critiquer
et juste intégré cette deuxième
découvert
la critique est inévitable je le savais
déjà j'ai rencontré des scientifiques
pour le partage et vivre cette
expérience va libérer et donc vu que
c'est inévitable et bien autant aller
faire ce qui me fait vibrer si ce qui
vous fait vibrer c'est de l'art autant
aller faire de l'art c'est voyager
voyager si c'est apprendre une langue
apprenez la langue faire un tour du
monde
partir dans l'espace créez votre
entreprise combien de personnes je vois
ne pas oser faire des choses qui sont
importantes pour elle juste parce qu'il
ya quelqu'un de leur entourage un ami un
enfant un parent un collègue de travail
qui leur dit c'est mort suite à ça je
peux aller plus loin dans un autre défi
quitté d'interviewer des personnes qui
excelle et j'ai pu interviewer quelqu'un
qui est un des plus grands acteurs
français comédien et qui fait aussi du
théâtre et en privé il m'a raconté une
anecdote de sa vie il est sur scène
devant une salle comme ça c'est
impressionnant ça c'est rare quand tu
rends dans une scène comme ça il est
19h30 le spectacle démarre à 20 heures
il est paniqué ils sont pas bien et
l'habitude au stress mais là c'est
particulier 19h45
toujours dans les loges et stressés ils
n'arrivent pas à se rappeler de son
texte
20 heures l'heure du début du spectacle
il est toujours dans les loges à votre
avis qu'est-ce qui se passe 20h15
toujours dans les loges paniqués les
mains moites
il est pas bien et plus le temps passe
plus 10 mai
avec la renommer que j'ai c'est vraiment
la honte de monter sur scène si je
bafouille si je connais pas mon texte
20h30 toujours dans les loges
c'était 30 minutes que la salle attend
son metteur en scène et perdu autant que
lui et luthier coup tu fais quelque
chose monte sur scène prend ton texte
vas-y dirigeait pas monté avec mon texte
c'est ridicule 20h45
il décide de prendre son texte est monté
sur scène à votre avis qu'est ce qui se
passe plus de ça il va passer tout le
reste de la pièce de théâtre avec le
texte à la main incapable de retrouver
son texte c'est long une pièce de
théâtre entière quand tu es stressé et
paniqué et que tu as ton texte à la main
et à la fin il va avoir la standing
ovation
la plus longue la plus grande qu'il a
jamais eu de toute sa carrière
trois ans plus tard il est dans une
autre ville il ya quelqu'un qui vient
les voir en lui disant mais j'étais là
c'était où j'étais là tu étais où
j'étais là ce soir là le soir vous aviez
votre texte
c'est peut-être pas pour vous le
meilleur spectacle de votre vie mais
pour moi ça a été le plus impactant dans
ma vie ce soir-là il a transformé ma vie
vous n'imaginez pas le nombre de choses
que je ne vais pas faire par peur d'être
critiqués parce que je me disais que
c'était pas encore parfait parce que
j'attendais d'être parfait pour démarrer
mon entreprise vous démarrez de parler
en public et ce soir là vous m'avez
libéré je me suis donné l'autorisation
d'aller réaliser mes rêves
merci merci club raconte cette histoire
ça n'impacte énormément parce que je me
rends compte que je suis extrêmement
attachée au regard des autres et en fait
on est extrêmement addict à être
valorisés par les autres et je me rends
compte qu'à partir du moment où tu te
libères du besoin d'être valorisés par
les autres il va tu te libères aussi au
passage d'être critiqué par les autres
et plus important accord que ça j'ai
fait une troisième découverte qui était
hyper importante pour moi c'est qu'en
réalité le seul risque que tu as quand
tu prends le risque d'être critiqué par
les autres c'est d'inspirer quelqu'un
c'est quelqu'un te vois tu entends tu te
regardent ils se disent il peut le faire
si elle peut le faire je peux le faire
aussi
combien ça vaut d'inspirer sa mère son
père ses enfants un inconnu
est ce que ça vaut pas une petite
critique quelqu'un qui va juste te dire
que ce que tu fais c'est nul
alors je vous ai parlé de beaucoup de
choses de plus en plus grande pour moi
mais il y avait un truc que josep
affaire qui pour beaucoup de gens
extrêmement simple et que j'ai laissé
chaque année passée en disant qu'il ne
ferait plus tard ça me terrorise est
bien plus que d'aller passer sur scène
en anglais c'est à dire je t'aime à mon
père
mon père il a été abandonné par son père
puis par sa mère puis par sa grand mère
il a eu du mal à comprendre ce que
c'était de se sentir aimé et du coup
j'ai eu d'adolescence je leur ai
beaucoup voulu et je prétextait manque
d'estimé de moi sur lui
dire je t'aime mon père c'était hyper
stressant pour moi bien plus que tout ce
que j'ai fait aujourd'hui de ma vie
encore une fois c'est cette peur du
regard des autres
la peur que mon père ne répondent pas la
peur qu'ils me rejette parce que je me
suis sentie rejetée par lui pendant
cette enfance et un jour je prends mon
téléphone et j'ai créé mon père papa je
t'aime faire ça
cet acte de courage pour moi c'était
plus important que plein de choses que
j'ai pu accomplir lendemain pas de
réponse de mon père le surlendemain pas
de réponse de mon père est le troisième
jour
j'oublie le sms le fait d'oublier le sms
en fait c'étaient des plus belles
victoires de ma vie parce que pour la
première fois de ma vie c'était plus si
important que mon père me reconnaisse ou
que quelqu'un me reconnaissent c'était
plus si important qu'il me réponde pas
ce que j'avais fait ce qui était
important pour moi de semaine s'écoule
mon père a tué pendant tout semaine se
demander qu'est-ce qu'on répond à un sms
comme ça parce que personne ne lui a dit
ça et après deux semaines la trouver une
formulation qui trouvais intéressante
la réciproque est vraie j'aurai reçu ce
sms à 15 ans je l'aurais voulu pour ça
mais quand je reçois se bat il ya
quelques années j'ai les larmes aux yeux
parce qu'en fait mon père je réalise par
toutes ces expériences le prendre mes
bras alors qu'il serait ce défi que mon
père en fait tu m'as toujours aimé sauf
que j'étais pas capable de le voir parce
qu'on a deux cerveaux différents et deux
enfants sont différentes
mon père m'a donné tout ce que lui n'a
pas eu un toit à manger des études et
quand je pensais qu'il me met pas ce qui
me disait assez fait attention continue
des études parce que moi je sais ce que
c'est de ne pas manger j'ai compris
qu'on perd en fait m'avait toujours aimé
et suite à ça ça a changé notre relation
est d'ailleurs j'ai beaucoup de
gratitude pour mon père aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils participent à la réussite
de mon entreprise
parce que j ai osé traverser ce regard
de l'autre et être prêt à trop vite et
par lui donc j'aimerais terminer par une
invitation l'invitation vous alliez
faire au moins une petite chose
inconfortable pour vous elle peut être
petit tous ceux des autres grandes pour
vous ça peut être un truc énorme aux
yeux des autres ou simplement levé la
main en cours parce qu'en fait j'imagine
un monde
et j'ose imaginer avec vous un monde où
si nous ensemble on ose faire des choses
qui nous inspire eh bien on pourra
peut-être voir ensemble un monde où il
ya des jeunes des enfants et des adultes
qui osent vivre la vie qu'il est libre
et peu importe ce que les autres pensent
et j'ai envie terminer avec cette phrase
de steve jobs ce que j'adore qui a
marqué ma vie
votre temps est limité ne le gâchez pas
en menant une existence qui n'est pas la
vôtre
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]